just because you're a cop why should you
have the right to tow the gun around
just because you have a bad you're
saying we shouldn't be honored you
shouldn't have guns at all okay next
time there's an active shooter going
into a university then we're just gonna
let him shoot all the students you know
what um I can't do this
episode
[Music]
agree with the prompt
cops should not carry guns
I mean there are so many countries in
this world that do not have this level
of violence within its law enforcement
department or any other department guns
themselves are not the issue
is the finger behind the gun because you
don't know the mentality the mind you
know the um heart of the person and
people things trigger people and they
snap
and no one exempt
police officer human beings too they can
snap if you took guns away from the
uniform I guarantee you like half of
them would not be there working you know
it's the power if you added the struggle
to to submit a a perpetrator and like
actually do work police work like it's
not just about reaching for your gun 99
of the time so it's like if the gun
wasn't part of the uniform a lot of them
wouldn't wouldn't take that enabling
role that they want to take as officers
yeah right in front of my building I was
harmed by older person older man when I
got away I went to the police
a detective took me to the hospital
everything checked me out you know what
the police officer did having a gun and
everything else pulled me over saying he
was taking me back home pulled me over
on a dark side
of a street and raped me
because
of the the uniform the badge and the gun
that made me
freeze but you as a police officer
saying that you were here to protect and
to serve
you allowed your power your your uniform
you got everything else to
think to make you think that that was
okay and this happens a lot it happens a
lot they want to abuse other people they
want to you know tyrants over other
people so they choose jobs like that
like what if you want to help other
people why can't you go be a
humanitarian there's oceans to clean up
instead like everybody just wants to be
out here taking rights away from others
and abusing people and getting guns and
the moment that your moment the moment
you start copying attitude literally
click listen let's go but you know what
I don't wanna I don't want to do that to
them
as they do it to us can the district
step forward
if someone else has a gun you gotta
defend yourself too you know just the
way you use it I'm not saying that you
should use guns but I mean if you have a
gun and you have to use it of course but
not use it just for traffic stops or or
people with mental illnesses stuff like
that that's not that's out if they have
a knife or a stick or you know or a fork
like that doesn't justify anybody
getting shot so you're for having armed
police officers if someone else has a
gun if someone else I believe that y'all
should be armed because I believe in the
Constitution I don't believe in the
policing that the police force has done
throughout many communities I've been in
but I do believe in rights versus laws
and I do believe that there are
dangerous scenes that you go to where it
is required to use them
so I have to agree that part of your
like he said is tool belt needs to
include a pistol okay good because I was
about to challenge you both and say okay
so you mean to tell me that what
happened at Michigan State University
would an active shooter
killing
five students orobaldi where they went
into an elementary school and killed
children Sandy Hook
Sandy Hook would happen over 10 years
ago
you're sitting there telling us that we
shouldn't be carrying firearms yeah you
shouldn't like if you guys are just
traffic cops and stuff like that you
guys shouldn't it
yeah you're not answering my question I
said I'm just going based on what you
said you called me a predator I'm like I
never done that in my life right I've
been in situations where I've been shot
at I had two members of my department
die in the last two months I've been in
situations where I've needed my firearm
I've needed every tool that I built in
my career you would go out and then see
half of the stuff I see you may change
your perception about what you see
it's it's dangerous so you can't call
for backup what is me calling for backup
have anything to do so if you work if
you were at County okay say in my area
I'm a County cop right and and in my
area I mean you have miles and miles of
nothing around you your closest partner
is maybe maybe if you're lucky 20
minutes away okay in the meantime I've
got somebody that's that has me at
gunpoint and if I don't have a gun on my
hip
I'm dead
I am a dead man walking because I have
nothing that can go up against another
gun how do you think felons feel there's
tasers pepper balls like societal issues
are not on the police like I'm not
stripping you of your rights right that
is not you can vote I don't give a [__]
you can vote you can carry a gun you can
do all that that is not my personal that
is not my job in life my job is you've
been you've been accused of a crime I
got to take it to jail because that this
now the Third I'm done you're saying
that we should have pepper spray tasers
to Michigan State University or ribaldi
is is that what you're saying so you're
telling me that if I'm a cop I have no
gun but also you said to the community
like maybe that's not what he said the
prompt is or should cause be unarmed
hold on a second you just got done
watching probably the most tragic
incidents in the probably historically
obali may I add this this kids for
crying out loud and what you're sitting
here saying is is that we shouldn't be
in our
what does it do would you like me to do
if someone has an AK-47 killing kids
that's my question to you we actually
have our own rights you know that we
actually have our own rights to carry
and defend ourselves in certain
situations like that you know but with
all the respect that's not the quite
that's that's not the question if you
want to use your body asking you if you
were okay I'll ask in a different way if
you're a police officer and you have no
firearms you got your pepper spray you
have your taser you have your uh your
baton and you are responding to obaldi
elementary school where there's an
active shooter with an AK-47
what are you going to do
um I would say that I would call for
backup to the proper authorities that
would be entitled to have those weapons
that are not in the general community
no but what entitled to have weapons who
what agency so like yeah
United Kingdom their special forces and
their Police Department have weapons but
they're regular so why should you just
why should you have the ability to just
tote around a gun that's my question to
you what's that my question to you is
just because you're a cop why should you
have the right to tow the gun around
just because you have a badge no no
that's not what you that's not what the
prompt is the prompt is cops being
unarmed
your body they took like over an hour to
respond
so you had the guns and you still didn't
what I'm saying he's saying cops cops is
a very when you say cops to me you're
talking to everybody
every single car okay and you're saying
we shouldn't be an arm
okay you shouldn't have guns at all okay
so you know what next time uh there's a
big uh active shooter going into a
university then I guess we're not we're
just gonna let him shoot all the
students so I have a question for you
so all the other all those countries
that don't have their um police officers
carrying guns not many just so you know
oh I know very well that's the work that
I do okay so
and even been there to see that but what
I'm saying is that have you ever thought
about how those countries respond to
those situations and can we do the same
we absolutely could not do the same
because we have we have criminals here
and and I'm not speaking of y'all but
there are people here that still carry
regardless of if it's against the law if
you were to take guns away from
illegals criminals people that that are
not from here I would 100 agree that
officers don't need guns
I think the mass Shooters are not the
ones the immigrants and the taking it
off and that's what I'm just giving
examples
she's right I mean yeah
not everybody I mean be specific if
you're allowed by the citizen to carry
guns the amount of guns that we have in
America doesn't it outweigh the people
that we have hey these countries they
don't have a second amendment they don't
have a constitutional right to bear arms
so it's a lot easier to say you know
what
y'all can't bury arms so y'all can't
bear arms in this country we can so I'm
just being like I said everything is
anecdotal I've been in situations where
I needed my gun and you are absolutely
right would I do the job without one
hell no because I've been in situations
where I needed one and you know what
I had it
it's equal force I'm being shot at I'm
about to shoot back not just hey I have
a gun in my hip how much about it you
know what guns guns guns guns that's not
how I do my job and the thing that
popped right from that prompt is just
active shooter active shooter active
shooter that's
it it's not even active shooter you know
it's just being shot at by itself if you
haven't done the research or I don't
know if there's any empirical data to
know exactly in other countries how they
respond
to someone who has an AK-47 that goes
into a building and starts killing
people and yet we're a police force that
doesn't have any farms I don't know I
would have to do the research they do
have special units where they're just
not out on the street where you see them
all the time 24 7. but you said
something and I want to bring it up hold
on one sec you said something you said
that the people with the guns are
oftentimes criminals or you know people
like that and I want to say that those
mass shootings that are that happen in
our country are from people that pass a
whole tons of background checks and um
are law abiding to your point and all
these things and all of a sudden and
that was my point earlier about when
people snap or whatever might happen and
we have to be clear in identifying that
because we get labeled like we're the
ones doing all these mass shootings all
these things that these horrible
egregious things and 90 96 of the time
yes it is not a person that was forming
a car we a little clear on that right
and then we get labeled as killers right
I think I've heard agents of racial
genocide is what we've been labeled
before uh you know and all this when and
again my point was just I'm talking
about one specific type of you know
incident where yeah everybody would
agree I think everybody would agree you
don't have to pay attention to that
though and be clear and be very honest
with that and and and identify it and
not try to like oh well it sounds good
and it's in and let's get some some news
on this and let's just like label them
and put everything on them because
that's how we feel because that is
actually what's happening and then when
we know the truth and the facts and it
comes out it's like that person was
never been incarcerated never had a
record never anything and to the worst
harm to our society our communities
because believe it or not the vast
majority of us on this side of the fence
want safety just as much as you do hey
good humans Zach here checking in to ask
if you're doing your best to protect
yourself from online crime anyone can
find anything on the internet including
your full legal name your email your
home address phone number and even your
relatives this information is accessible
because of data Brokers you profit by
selling your information to spammers
telemarketers and anyone else that wants
to learn more about you that's why I'm
excited to tell you about today's
sponsor aura
Aura provides all-in-one digital safety
for your devices to protect you from
online threats
they have almost every Internet safety
tool you'll ever need including a VPN
password manager real-time credit and
identity theft monitoring and more all
in one easy to use app Aura does the
hard work of keeping you safe online and
if you sign up right now by going to
aura.com Jubilee Media or I will give
you a two-week free trial so you can
start protecting yourself and your
information be sure to check out the
link in the description or scan the QR
code to start your free trial today
thanks so much to Aura for sponsoring
this episode now let's get back to the
video
police violence is blown out of
proportion
I think that really depends on where
you're at whether it's City town I think
it really depends on the department
because you have a lot of departments
that you see a lot of that stuff but
then you have like the smaller
departments that you don't see none of
that and you have community policing you
know we go out and we do activities with
the kids we do activities with families
yes we still do our job we still pull
people over but we're not I guess what
you would call harassing people
in some of the some of the ways that the
big cities do but I mean you technically
are though like I mean justifying your
bad behavior and your violence for you
guys doing community work it just
doesn't go hand in hand you know I
understand people sentiment where one
incident where it looks extremely bad is
wrong and then it casts an entire
umbrella over the entire profession I
may have a different persp uh
perspective or different perception of
what you're looking at than you do
because I'm in this profession but the
way that I guess that we look at things
now in the media gets blown completely
out of proportion so when we see the
videos of a police officer handling a
child and that cop has become violent
towards a child and I agree but my thing
is has it been blown out of abortion I
see that one incident we see it all
locked
you do see it a lot but you have to also
take in consideration that there's over
1800 agencies in the entire entire
United States so if you look at the big
grand scheme of things as it relates to
all these agencies and you do see
violence you do see where it's
scrutinized where it's brutal but
if you take the numbers
it's it's very very minimal if you look
at all the public contacts with all
agencies Nationwide compared to these
bad incidents or the perception of bad
incidents it's a very micro compared to
the macro of how many public contacts
all the agencies have those are the ones
that you do see I mean and then before
we brought up earlier about the media
blowing it up and we agree we agree to
that there was you know Rodney Kane
there was Emmett Till There is always
and you know and honestly there's bad
officers and good officers will be the
first ones to tell you there are bad
officers there's bad off there's bad in
every every Workforce that you're in
everything if it's bad it's bad if it's
wrong it's wrong you know we are the
first ones to kind of hey you know
that's that's too far and I used to work
Internal Affairs and I personally
arrested two prior police officers I
also worked Internal Affairs and I can
tell you out of 30 plus of these
tribunal hearings a lot have been
terminated so there is some
accountability I think we're heading in
the right direction considering 20
something years ago you know you did
something bad and you know it got sweat
now social media obviously has magnified
it by hundreds and hundreds which is
good Oso media has done is just allowed
everyone to see what's happening in the
moment right before we got it Weeks
Later months later years later so no one
knew what was going on but now we have
the ability to film it in a moment and
say hey look at this and this is what's
being captured if violence that's
perpetrated against people whether
they're doing something wrong or not is
so I mean it's to the point where it's
not even harmful anymore it's tragic why
because we're all human beings
and there's a culture of violence that
perpetuates within the department itself
and I've had good cops reach out to me
reach out to me and said they're not
listening and if I say if they know I'm
saying anything
I'm gone or I'm going to be hurt police
violence is completely blown out of
proportion in a sense that it's
completely biased why isn't non-violence
or me saving someone's life not blown
out of proportion can the disagree step
forward
I don't believe it's blown out of
proportion because I believe it's just
barely getting the exposure that it
needs it is what it is that's what it is
each each time I've encountered the
classes it's just been like the most
negative experience of my life like uh
I'm addicted to the news
and every time I try on news it's
another cop kid and like you said maybe
they don't report what's good out there
but they do report the bad and I watched
I watched it every day of my life like I
see how the cops treat people if I may
ask you if you did see the good would
that give you a different perception
about the police it's not that I don't
see the good it's that it just doesn't I
haven't seen it happen I haven't
experienced it I haven't had heard
nobody in my community like right have
anything so I've seen the good when I
was 16 years old I'm in my 40s I
actually had a police officer who was my
hero every contact sense in multiple
States multiple divisions has violated
me stolen from me taken from me a script
me of every value I ever had the way
y'all talk to me the approach I'm so
respectful
eighteen thousand that's what you said
division no 1800 1800 how many prisons
are there
and how many inmates and then we're
disarmed when we come home we can't vote
so I can't compete with you on my laws
I can't carry a gun I can't defend
myself I can't even carry a knife
the exposure is barely there we need
more exposure
I'm from the LA County area
from the islands of Hawaii originally
every police in between them Seas to the
east coast is always spoken with
disrespect they don't pull us over on a
speeding ticket like hi how's your day
how are you doing do you got any
emergencies going on
what's the last time you was arrested
who me no I'm just saying that's the
approach when you come to the car window
right is on guard I don't talk like that
so I hear where you're coming from but I
don't talk like that so some people do
do that
you talk for them but you said us you
just pointed at us said us the
department all departments I don't know
which department they work for but I
work for a department and it's I've
never seen this person these people in
my life I've never seen you in my life
I've never encountered you in my life
but I wouldn't come at you like that so
you don't cuss at people when you walk
up today we're like welcome to them no
now if they're cussing at me I might cut
back absolutely I'm going to allow you
to dictate how you're going to allow
just this interaction to go what if I
speak to you with respect and you go
back then you pull my license in the
sense
you're still going to get treated I've
never not one time so you guys are four
you can come do right along with me but
what I'm saying is I'm coming to you
what are you on parole yeah
she doesn't tell you you got to do your
job yeah the dynamic the Dynamics change
because everybody's got body worn video
now or dashboard video and everything is
recorded all this contacts that's
exactly why you guys have body cams and
dash cams because transformational
departments don't trust for transparency
so if I do something the public knows
why I did something that's what it's for
I grew up in the era of camera so I'm
fine with it I turn it on every single
time I've had people say hey this person
is rude this person just now in the
third day watch the body cam did nothing
that they said Bingo and the technology
is policing you so technology has little
air human beings are policing Us in the
community of a community that you don't
even know our values you come from 30
miles away is the difference in the
values so I believe that it does need
more exposure beyond the cameras that
y'all I think if it if you're going to
say it needs more exposure I think the
good side also needs more exposure I
think policing in a hole needs more
exposure I mean I grew up with that in
school dare programs and all these false
hopes but that's not the difference it
has nothing to do with Patrol and being
out on the streets and working with
people and families out on the streets I
see the good in policing but I also see
the bad in policing so like I said if
it's gonna if it if this one side needs
more exposure I think it all needs more
exposure
I grew up in the community
I'm not judging you but yet you see me
with a uniform you automatically judge
me and I don't think that's fair well
that because that comes from her
experience that's that's what she's
trying to say it's like as soon as the
uniform is put on to the badge it like
and for most because I'm in that work
and I see it and it's like the ego comes
in or that power and as human beings we
must feel like we're in control that's
just it just seems to be an innate thing
within all of us oftentimes people with
titles and roles allow the titles and
roles
to justify
what they do
the good is there the good is there
there's four of you right here
you have some conscience that's what I'm
hearing committing a crime is never
Justified
does anybody agree with the prompt no
no he's a crime now can the disagree a
step forward
that prompt it's a very open-ended
question I shared my part of my story
earlier about the person the officer who
was there to protect serve
and he committed a crime
against me
was he justified
because he was a police officer a
detective
I forgave him
and so that's why I couldn't step
forward because I had to pause for a
second I just I I have to take a neutral
stance here because that's not our
reality
um I was 14 years old and I was
deciding to not go to school
and my stepdad came up and yanked a
cover out from underneath me and I hit
the ground off of a bunk bed and I got
up cussing him and he slapped me across
my face and I was the one that was taken
to juvenile hall but damn it my crime
was justified you know I think with
anybody with any crime that is committed
there's a reason there's a background
there's a story there you go there's
circumstances that you have to find out
and us as police officers that's our job
you know and
we'll we'll take it from there so none
of you is officers stepped forward and
felt like it was unjustifiable the
minute that you put your badge on to
commit a crime
right I feel like some things are
Justified for basic survival I'm just
curious four of you didn't have that one
concept and you took an oath to protect
and serve my community his community
your community her community and not one
of you stepped forward I was going to
step forward and challenge it I
hesitated and went back because I wanted
to rethink it not one of you felt like
when you put on that badge in that tool
belt that there was no justifiable
reason to commit a crime because it'd be
self-defense right some things are just
I can just said basic survival I deal
with transients all the time right hey
go and steal something my department
requires me to do something when
somebody steals something now do I think
it's right no but he's hungry I got I
have it's my job so I have to do
something where I'm gonna get fired can
I pull out my my card and and I've done
that no I've done that but I can't my
department doesn't allow me to do that
so I can't do that I have to do
something they say hey I want him to go
to jail he's going to jail based on what
that person said with your situation if
she would have the Knights of the
officer that's Justified to me right my
eyes yeah now do we have Justified being
justified and generally what the
consequences are two different things
I'm totally accountable my years in
prison made me 100 accountable for me
and every action that I do and every
thought that I make um so I've served
federal and state prison I have a parole
until 2036 for Narcotics I've never hurt
anybody nobody's ever overdosed for my
drugs I just got caught under the Reagan
laws I was raised and I've created my
deepest friendships that I have in there
I've left women behind in there the
problem is is that when I found myself
in trouble since I've been home the last
number I would call is anything with one
one two one one four one one or nine one
one my loss of faith and belief in the
whole
whole entire police Community is gone it
ain't no two percent of you in my eyes
there ain't no one percent
because you might be a hero one day and
it's 16 years later back against the
corner lose everything you stood for and
it happens we're humans just a problem
anything that you've done to
get you where you were was never
Justified uh if you look at justifiable
no I was greedy I was taught a Hustle
but why did you start
because I was hungry
you were Justified but you're still
going to get arrested that's what I'm
saying no I don't justify it I'm
accountable see there's a difference
that's not what I'm saying I understand
where you come from but I'm still going
to arrest you I'm still going to because
this is a job yeah so I understand your
story I hear you but you're still going
to jail that's what I'm saying is it
Justified I get it you were hungry you
have to do what you have to do you have
to do what you have to do to survive I
get it
but you're still going to jail you're
doing a job that the department told you
to do right you just said that would you
want it to come out your pocket to
probably feed the person that was
stealing something because they hungry
because in your Humanity you know what
it's like to be hungry but in your job
you know that if you don't do what
you're told and the the right the the
procedures and stuff that you're going
to get in trouble you probably lose that
job and that's not something you want to
do because you also have to feed your
family feed yourself right absolutely so
I think we can all agree some of you
have good intentions and you go go in
with that but it's a department that has
a culture of violence you can't help but
to pick up some of those traits
a number one because you want your job
a number one so I served 27 years in
prison and a Maximum Security Prison for
Women I had a sentence of 25 to life for
the crimes of kidnapping and murder
that's what I was convicted of
did I do it that's a different story no
person that represented a system
helped me
punishment has become the response to
every damn thing in this country because
it's like we're out in the street living
every day to survive we're on the street
doing our own thing when you guys as
colleagues come after us like at what
point does it justify your colleagues to
do all that stuff just because they have
that badge when y'all colleagues are
shooting at us how does that justify you
guys's crimes that's what I understood
from her I understood like when you guys
are yeah yeah I'm I I was agreeing with
what you're saying you're out in the
streets and you know you guys come and
do all this and that what who's calling
who's calling us to get to where you're
at all right let me give you a perfect
example right okay let's say I have a
broken down car you know okay I have a
broken down car and uh nobody called you
you just happened to see a broken down
car and I have my emergency lights on
too so I'm declaring that I'm having an
emergency situation okay you see me out
and about I'm on my phone I'm in a safe
area on this side on the right side of
my vehicle where I'm not in imminent
danger I'm following all my protocols
let's see I even go as far as putting a
road flare or a cone from like a traffic
kit I'd cover all my T's and A's you
know I'm literally trying to avoid you
because I don't like you so I'm doing
everything I got to do but here you go
hey what's up do you need help and I'm
like no sir I don't need any help I've
called Triple A they're on their way I
verbally communicated with you that I'm
good I'm in no imminent danger I put my
cones up I'm waiting for AAA I relate to
you verbally communicated that I'm okay
I'm not bleeding you're not seeing
anything going on with me that would
attract you to come after me
but here you are grabbing on your belt
pulling out your thing just seeking for
something to go after immediately see
like you're like a predator bro you're
literally Hawking eye into your Target
and you're like I'm gonna get them boom
and here you go you've been drinking
today I'm like bro I just told you I
don't need your help like I'm sitting
here waiting for my my trip away to come
with a flat tire because I got a wheel
lock oh so but have you been drinking
today are you on probation or parole
immediately it's like dude
I'm in distress I've advised you I don't
need your help right put up all my
flares crossed all my teeth dotted on my
eyes but you continue to push the
subject yeah as far as like pulling your
gun I mean why are you getting hostile
sir I'm not saying it doesn't clip it
I'm just saying hostile sir
you're good so I feel like you're
getting hostile super tries where I
could see him click there we go so I'm
gonna tell you what I always just say in
the streets when I well I mean do we
agree here that's what I was gonna say
I'm gonna tell you what I always say in
Patrol you know and this is what my
earlier comment where we get painted
with this broad brush first of all I
would have given you a ride when you say
you I just want to make sure and be
clear that me personally that's why
though hold on hold on let me finish let
me finish what I'm saying is is that in
my mind you're speaking about me me
personally I would have helped you no
matter what but I don't need your help
I've advised you very much
I would have took off went to Strawberry
so I got a cup I understand that but
when I'm saying this is that I'm going
to tell you what I always used to say
when I used to work in the streets you
know what I can't speak and I can't feel
what you feel why did you let me finish
let me finish
bro exactly nobody who called you
but
nobody called you
okay
he doesn't understand can we get a
little protocol he started the Q a where
he talks and then I talk because he's
not letting me talk okay you can respond
I don't want to hear from Scott and then
you have to go to the next one can you
just like please let me finish okay I'm
answering the valid points validly you
know what you're saying you're not
letting me you know what disregard it's
good we don't have to be button you know
I gotta I gotta say like what I'm trying
but you gotta have more patience as a
police officer you just got a quick snap
and I can see it
again when I argue
as much as you can I think and then once
the crime that was committed like when I
was a kid up I wanted to be a cop I saw
the cops they were I grew up in the 90s
um so they would give baseball cards and
I thought the cost was the coolest
things because I had like I had a real
real bad childhood like with my parents
and I didn't really have um friends like
that but the cops will be there
but the second I got my Low Rider bike
like the cops would pull me over and
give me tickets and I'd be like why
don't you stop them over there it's like
well we're stopping you how are we going
to stop them and then I'll get tickets
constantly I was just a kid I didn't
know what I was doing I I like the
lowrider culture and they would give me
tickets all the time then my parents
would be like why are you getting
tickets like I don't know they just keep
stopping me and then like maybe I did
School in the Costco like you know like
sometimes they'll get me from a certain
neighborhood and drop me off in a like
far away from my house like or sometimes
and I was a minor and they'll get me
from the streets and take me to the
police station which I found out later
was illegal that and and they made me to
Hawaii who I am and they made me think
that I was a bad guy until like I
realized almost like 13 years ago I
don't got to be that bad guy no more but
the cost made me who I who I was I don't
share like I I've never like I've never
served any time like that I was arrested
as a 13 year old you know literally I
still looked like I was 10. I was
smoking weed at the park and I got
immediately apprehended taking into
custody I got handcuffed behind my back
and then I got placed in a cop car with
no no divider it was like a park cop you
know so no divider and then when he
asked he started asking me about my name
and stuff so I was like the Adolescent
you know adolescent phases I didn't want
to answer them but I have to why not
though he's a liar because you don't
have to you don't have to enter without
my parents you don't have the right to
talk to them that's incorrect you
committed a crime correct see but I mean
you know but I don't think you're what
all right one second one second one
second gotcha so without the without the
barrier and he kept asking me questions
and I just simply didn't want to answer
him I didn't have to at that point you
know so he got upset that I didn't you
know volunteer with whatever his demands
were and he just punched me in the chest
as a handcuffed 13 year old kid knocked
the wind out of me whatever you know it
went as far as violating my rights I
never even knew that I could have told
his commanding officers or even the
Watch Commander once I got to the jail
you know this guy like sucker punched me
in the chest like he knocked the one out
of me he abused me he abused a minder I
didn't know any of that now that I'm
gonna die oh because I'm a felon because
of course that you know escalated into
more things like getting marijuana and
marijuana was highly legal back then
I'll be damned if you guys mess with me
like all over again and that has
happened to me I I get it that's why I
got road flares in my car that's why I
keep like a kick I cross all my T's and
all my eyes dude criminals who commit
violent felonies don't deserve certain
legal rights
you know what um I'm sorry I can't do
this
for this episode
it's not making any sense that the
questions
sorry I can't really get my point across
how I want to and the questions are kind
of like reverse like it's like you're
asking a question but you kind of I I
can't do it I totally understand you can
always share whether you agree or
disagree
I can't be on camera doing that I I
totally understand I get my point across
that the police you know what I mean but
I can't do that yeah like I can't do
that and I can even get my point across
there's no point of me being here
can we take a smoke break then
I can
I fear the other side
step forward if you agree
you know I think um it's part of their
job to put fear in us but it shouldn't
you know every time uh just for a
traffic ticket or just being stopped on
the street it was always like guns drawn
right away
you know and every time
they Point their guns at me especially
towards my back when I'm not even
looking
like it just gives me this fear like and
then not only that they like to
manhandle you they like to like grip on
your your knuckles when you already know
the procedure I spread my legs and I try
to do everything right and they still
try to manhandle you each time they try
to like hold you so you could react and
do something it's like that that it's
like their job is to incriminate us and
every for every traffic ticket it was
always like I always have my driver's
license my insurance so every time
they'll come at me I'll start cursing
them out like that was me that that was
my whole from ever since I turned 18 to
I was like 30. I was just cursing them
out every chance I get and I'll love it
because they'll give me a ticket each
time and I'll be like okay like I don't
care like I'm paying for my freedom and
that's that was the cost of my opinion
my freedom but I did feel from my life
each time every time like they manhandle
me and and talk down to me all I would
think about was my kids like them if my
kids wanted to see how these people act
because my kids look up to me but to see
the cops like act this way and then
laugh about it you know who are these
people like they they bring fear to the
community they don't bring any peace or
nothing like that you know and that's
how I grew up I grew up with so much
aggression towards the cops like so much
aggression until I realized you know
what I'm not who they they they they
made me to be I have a dangerous job
just like how you have children
I don't know if everybody has children
I want to go home to see my children so
I don't necessarily fear the other side
I just fear what could happen if I let
my guard down while I'm doing my job
that's it once you start off aggressive
I kind of have to match that because in
the back of my head
why are you being aggressive I have to
understand hey he's being aggressive for
some reason I don't want to die I don't
want you to die you don't want to die I
would hope that you don't want me to die
and we just meet in the middle right
there back then I would hope a car hits
his thumb or something because the cops
will come out with their guns drawn it
wasn't even though like I'll just be
spooked and and once they they they come
to me I'll be like you [__] I'll
just go off on them in my younger days
like I'd never just pointed my gun for
no reason but I was little you know what
the [__]
now it's like oh okay I mean it's just
interesting how all you guys stayed back
there and didn't come and I think you
guys decided to come and show that you
do have fear but I don't think you guys
really fear us you know the way we fear
you you keep saying that it's not you
and he's gonna keep saying that's not
him so who is it nobody because if it's
black and white do I fear you no
I don't even know you to fear you I
signed up for the fact that one day I'm
gonna get shot and 20 plus years ago I
couldn't agree with you more I totally
totally understand that brutality and
how we treat people we treat them like I
get that
fast forward 25 years ago it because of
all that treatment that we did now you
have
um ambushes you know you got situations
where suspects you know people are
coming up the cops and just executing
them and you know so when the prompt
says you know do I fear the other side
well yeah I mean the other side is
someone who wants to take my life out
and doesn't even know me and I suppose
that's a consequence of what happened
decades ago where we did treat people
like I just had to say this story let's
be clear
what we're hearing right now there's
trauma right and it's just triggering oh
absolutely and so what we're going off
of our reality what's happening what
continues to happen it it causes us as
human beings to become defensive it
causes become protective it causes us to
become things that we're not but we
weren't born and it shouldn't exactly
like I should not have to exactly stay
inside my house and become an intern and
it's like why can't I enjoy my freedoms
I'm a tax paying American I mean I know
I'm a felon and I can't have certain you
know rights but
when when does my fear of you guys
impede me from living my life as a free
American I'm only 30 years old so I'm
dealing with the consequences of what
people have done in the past but it's
like I'm not like that so it's like I
get the trauma but it's also like I'm
trying to change it allow me to change
it you know I do have to say something
like the cars from the 90s are very
different from the new cops because now
they got a whole bunch of different
races before it was mostly whites so
that's what I had to deal with in the
90s but now it's a little different I
could say that can the disagree step
forward I agree with this gentleman here
about the job as danger factors
um coming across people on the field and
Patrol
I didn't
fear them because I treated them with
the most respect and I treated them the
way I would want my family to be treated
if they were on the other end being
stopped I've had arrestees
after going to the jail and processing
them getting food whatever
a handful would say you know what thank
you for treating me with the most
respect I honestly I live in anxiety
every day every time I see a black and
white cop every time I see you ready I
totally uniform I hear a little too much
keys I hear
I just don't um you know little noises
that come with your guys's uniforms I
sat up here for 15 minutes and was going
to turn around because I did not want to
be in a room with four people that wore
that badge and it's come to that much of
a broken trust because I am the most
friendliest human that you'll meet I
trust everything even a stranger walking
as soon as I see a uniform I'm totally
guarded and I live in anxiety because of
it me with my parole I could show
license registration insurance with a
smile
oh why you got a parole till 2036 step
out of your vehicle next thing you know
my little tiny belongings are on the
side of the curb and it's not even
getting put back together
and then I'm late for work now I got to
explain to a job that hired a felon why
I'm late because someone had a busy day
and they saw that I had a pearl date if
you don't know my drama I don't expect
you to evaluate it but I don't expect a
tough tone either because it might
trigger me and then we both gonna be all
types of business
so what I want to know is how you guys
feel about the day we're scared of you
guys
I hate it yeah because how do I gauge
that I don't know I guess I have to keep
continue to ask questions this is my
third but I'm like why the hell I'm just
talking to you like if I saw it like I
said because you can only put a animal
in the corner for so long before they
fight back but I think that's what
that's what the police wants I think
that's they won a war they want us to
fight back because I wanted to fight
back so long until I realized I wasn't
that person and I had to just go my way
like follow the path that God gave me in
and I had to leave that alone but I did
have a
uglier path that I was going to follow
but it's like you know the cops it's
like you guys make yourself our enemy I
don't enjoy conflict we're all scared of
you and everybody I know is scared of
the promise when you interact with me
or with any of you guys I'm gonna
understand who you are as a person and
it kind of goes back to what he had said
about match energy with energy you know
pretty people that's if that was the
case I mean we don't really fear you we
don't we're not scared I'm not scared of
you one bit if I had a gun with a boss
go at it we'll do a door or something
like that and it will be even other than
that I'm not scared of you guys but it's
just the fact that a lot of times we
don't have guns we don't have nights
like against things you guys think we're
ninjas that we're just gonna throw a
knife or a forking it's going to land in
your eye and then you guys it is that's
not that's not how we're living that's
not the reality that bad gives you guys
all the power what community are you
from because I hear Dwayne Tennessee
okay so where do you police Tennessee
you police in Tennessee so do you police
in the community you grew up in I do
okay so out here in La is pretty
different
okay our police like the beat they might
live there for 25 30 years and live over
here now because they've made it out or
they might actually come from somewhere
they wanted a police but they send them
to Long Beach you know so a big factor
is that that badge that you put on you
took a responsibility to know that I
don't trust you we can have
commonalities I probably can't have a
commonality with you even if you said
that it was your passion other than if
we could get to the the way above you
because you're like the bottom of the
trickle effect of the system I need
friends yeah once you put on that
uniform in that badge
for me I'm on guard no matter who you
are you're 100 right we have a lot of
work to do shows like this us coming
together and having this dialogue it's
only going to try to get us
you know not only just a middle ground
but to treat each other as humans so we
have a lot of work to do I totally get
it I agree
policing is necessary
releasing is necessary
[Laughter]
I agree because I was kidnapped raped
and tortured and it was an off-duty La
Sheriff officer who was out of
jurisdiction
play a softball he it was during
Payphone days he saw red flags he was
policing you know he did his job
[Music]
he noticed Damsel in Distress I guess
and he called local authorities and the
gentleman got a double life sentence due
to the horrendous crimes he committed
against me so I do believe that policing
is necessary in certain perspectives
however I'm going to be biased I think
that y'all don't need a police
struggling you know
so I do believe that there is a reason
and a purpose for your positions I'm
sorry that happened to you and I'm sorry
that happened to you I'm a parent and I
have a daughter I have a mother I have a
sister and I would never want anything
like that to happen and what you went
through was horrendous and we have
checks and balances in place for that
moving forward with a lot of
transparency I think there are a lot of
changes in regards to issues with that
like I said I mentioned earlier I
personally arrested two of our own
officers working Internal Affairs for
the crimes that they committed it didn't
go over well but it had to be done and
those are the checks and balances of
transparency the these agencies have in
place so we are not
are healed
race of humans we are not in a healthy
place we haven't been in a healthy Place
probably ever
but we have to get there it's not
working
it causes more harm than it does good
because even if a hundred police
officers do good it takes out one to do
something so atrocious it's so bad
that it just wipes all the good away and
it shouldn't and it shouldn't but it
does hungry people are going to steal
to eat
and that's the thing we're not looking
at the root causes of stuff yes the four
of you what I'm hearing you sound like
really good human beings
that have a job
or chose a job to maybe you wanted to
protect and serve and whatever else and
knew that there was bad things that
happened you want to help with that
that's I understand that and it's true
but it gets lost and it gets murky
when we continue to see the things that
happen
policing is necessary but it depends on
how you police
if I wasn't that good I do believe y'all
need to be policed as well though I
believe that you spend you as police
officers spend way too much time
policing us and not enough time police
seeing each other and on all the videos
100 has shown the facts of what Partners
do you know they stand by they don't
police each other they don't say hey
stop bruh hold up my homeboys if I'm
acting a fool and they know my felony
they're gonna stop me they're going to
say get back over here Bonnie get calm
yourself you got too much to lose
all the videos where there's one Gone
Wild
not policing each other right so to your
point is that a bill too yeah well not
only that yeah so yeah they just they're
just an active duty to intercede so or
intervene right so yeah right now you
you act a fool and you start acting up
and your partner's there and you just
watching that's not going to cut it
you're going to get jammed up and
probably get uh terminated me personally
look I'm in my uh 25 24 25 years I spent
about 12 years in discipline so I worked
Internal Affairs and I prosecuted cops
so I'm 100 with you I don't think any of
us here would like to have a bad actor
or a liar you know or a murderer for
that meaning or a rapist or you know so
that in it itself it's just not
tolerated whatsoever because we're
trying to do what's good um is police
needed for me on a personal note
I had a sister
who was molested and raped when she was
young my older sister
and she got heavily into drugs she's a
27 year veteran of meth and um
ended up getting arrested she
ended up having to go through the system
and you know I suppose at one point she
got a drug diversion
but all those years of all those better
all those series that she did drugs it
really affected her physically to the
point where she ended up getting ovarian
cancer and so two years ago I lost her
to terminal cancer
my nephew her son the Apple didn't fall
far from the tree he also committed a
lot of crimes and you know what if it
wasn't the police arresting him and
going through the system
he probably will be dead right now right
now he said he committed crimes out here
in Los Angeles and he's now over in
another state where he committed more
crimes and now luckily thank God that
he's actually going through this systems
at a halfway house has been sober for I
think over a year so the police for me
not just internally for what I did but
it's super necessary for others
thank you I mean we do need policing in
a way but not this type of policing
you know that that's it it's just this
is not it we need to find a another way
you know and you know I don't mean to be
funny but I'm pretty sure you guys uh if
you haven't seen the movie Judge Dredd I
mean they get to the point they don't
take nothing personal they do their job
they get spit on they get talked back um
and the cops just do their job they were
their judges but not cause but they just
do their job that's it nothing personal
it's just business because it is a
business because everything that has to
do with the police either has something
to do with money or money comes out of
it but that's it you just you just got
to take the the person the personal
stuff out the equation at the equation I
think will will be all right and I mean
compassion it I mean it goes hand in
hand but like I said just do your job in
that you don't got to go nowhere beyond
that
so you're 50 50.
you think we should abolish this
policing and start a new Wing but you're
for the police as long as it's a better
system
it used to be something else not the the
whole police policing everything that
has police in it just needs to get out
the way it needs to be a new way of of
going about things so if you said you
had kids right I have four
okay if my daughter is raped
I need an officer that is willing to be
my child's voice
and hold
the rapist accountable
okay I was raped
none of my family believed me
okay nobody
but that one officer that I spoke to
that one cop
believed me
and made sure that everything was
handled appropriately
and charges actually stuck
but what's the odds of you in that one
cup
I've had I I've lost all hope in 9-1-1
and calling cops I don't care my
community can take care of whatever
happens that comes towards my family and
I do believe that y'all need a police
insert like in perspectives but not
um how would I say not yeah like the
badge in the uniform ain't working no
more we all agree that something we need
something better nah I don't agree at
all not one bit I literally believe like
the we we should be able to
um take care of ourselves fend for
ourselves you know I mean so you're so
if you have a three-year-old daughter
that gets kidnapped or raped
your same situation well I mean I'm
gonna go how is she gonna defend herself
um I'm going to become an automatic
criminal and probably face charges for
taking matters upon my own hands I'm
going to fall into the cycle and if you
couldn't find the rapists or the
kidnapper I mean to be honest with you
like I hate to put it this way but I've
been a victim of crimes that I've solved
myself before you guys even got involved
and crimes have happened to me that I've
delivered literally I've delivered I've
handed cases to investigators and I've
done you know my thing I'm not going to
go out and shoot people I got too much
to lose but I will do my job and I will
do what I got to do because it's my
stuff I'm paying my tax dollars are
paying for you guys to do absolutely
nothing and when you guys are called
I'm open a beer I'm gonna chill I'm
gonna hang out I'ma probably order a
pizza the pizza man will get there
before you guys do your civil servants
of us when when at what point did you go
from serving us to harassing us at what
point did you go from serving and
protecting us to making us
inferior to you guys at what point do we
go from
the people
to man we're scared of you guys and I
hear you honestly I hear you I hear
everything you're saying
I honestly have a better chance of
policing myself than I haven't call you
guys well I'm sorry you went through
what you did okay I will apologize for
us as a whole
but you can't judge all of us
it's not just you guys it's a whole
history since you guys started like in
1777 when this country was built there
was no police I have trouble especially
uh being a black cop is I have been
through what you've gone through
yet when I try to be a better person
every time I talk to somebody with
trauma like what you're saying you judge
me based off this but then expect me not
to do the reverse to you and I don't
understand where that disconnect is well
the distance if I were to treat you like
gosh this is just this Mexican on the
street right all the time I don't know
you so I've never done that so don't say
I've done that right but if I were to
treat you like that it would be an issue
why do you feel okay to do that hey this
is a cop he's going to do the exact same
[__] everybody else did it before I
that's not fair to do it's not but it's
not fair to come after me when I'm just
driving my car I don't know you the
Constitution says that I have the right
to enjoy my roads that I paid for myself
you have the right to travel yeah it
would travel freely travel freely that's
the key right travel freely right so you
can walk wherever you want to go but you
can't drive that's under the California
Constitution but that's neither here nor
there but what I'm saying I would never
this is pay attention guys I want you
guys to pay attention right I want you
guys to pitch because this is a big
problem right here and and he claims
that he's not a problem he's in the
middle but let me let me point it out to
you guys right here where the big flaw
is every time that I've invoked my
rights this individual has chose to go
around and still violate my rights
notice that okay the same the same
Persona the same you know what I mean
yeah
can we move on to the last prompt again
locking people up doesn't solve anything
finally Middle Ground punishment
is the response to everything by
punishment I mean throwing somebody into
a system that does not address anything
any of the issues that the person might
have had the communities have people
with substance uh issues mental health
issues um poverty issues let's be clear
poverty is a crime right but people are
getting locked up for it because they're
trying to manage and and eat and and
survive and just do you know and so
we're not addressing anything that
causes these ills okay let's lock them
up and throw away the key that's the
mindset Lakes that's how we feel because
we lived it and we continue to live it
yeah I think we've gotten better and and
right and I feel like that's where now
we find we're under getting this middle
ground and this understanding that it is
not the way to do things it is not the
solution right I feel like we're getting
the blame for it
when it's a system as a whole
you know we don't have anything to do
with what what happens well you're part
of it and well we're we are part of it
absolutely we we absolutely agree on
that she that's the thing that you guys
say oh we're not responsible but then
you say that oh we're not like this but
I mean we're responsible no one's taking
us no one's taking accountability that's
one thing I mean you guys say sorry for
your apologizing for them but where are
they like you know it's like we never
see them you're the stage before intake
so you're the level before I go in so
when I'm putting handcuffs and going in
my last real human contact
is with the person who put the handcuffs
on me and not once has anyone ever like
ever just had a compassionate like hey I
hope to see you make it out of here
healthy or hey you know what I'm I'm we
should have just been 70 percent for God
knows how long like 80 something yeah
probably 80 now and certain ZIP codes in
certain locations it's probably even the
90 or 95 so from a societal you know
point of view absolutely I think that
you know locking people up is not the
key as a matter of fact all the prisons
that they made in state of California
has been overpopulated for decades
there's money in recidivism there's not
money in reformation and that's the
problem is that you you are trapped in a
system and so am I whereas all about a
dollar amount on me and that's just what
it is like you know when I got locked up
like I went in for weed and when I got
out like in two weeks I came out like
knowing how to steal a car I made more
connections with more criminals I
learned how to make a shack I learned
how to hide stuff like I I became more
criminal going to prison going to jail
or it's like you just are surrounded by
other people that are doing even crazier
stuff than just having weed so it's like
I came out worse and each time I will go
I will learn something even worse so
it's like it just makes you even worse
imagine like having a family for 13 27
years right and then you come home and
you're told you can't associate with
them
like those are my friends in their home
I'm home we relied on each other
violation 10-day sit down
oh what's your name is all about the
dollar amount
all my support is stripped because
their feelings
what support do I have not y'all not the
feelings I'm in the middle line too who
supports me my job
we need some help
on all on both sides at all levels
um going back what you said about
financials yeah it is it's at the
legislative branch that where they need
to make these changes and it's going to
trickle down where it affects all of us
on both sides and we have not we have
not really brought the elephant
to light in this room right now this
system is not ours right it was created
before any of us here
um was designed to continue a form of
slavery
period the vast majority of the 2.3
million people in American prisons and
jails are black and brown
people period it's broken and I don't
see Our Generations being able to fix it
I don't see the Next Generation but I
will tell you I will do my part
as an individual to uphold and treat
everybody with respect as I'm sure all
three of these guys can say as well you
know I didn't know y'all from Adam I
don't know them from Adam but here we
are we're having conversations we're
having debates and I will still treat
you guys all with the same respect and
thank you so much guys for being here
[Music]